[Music]
and five
hello and welcome to the view from 22
which is the new show on spec TV to
discuss some of the issues of the week
in a more in-depth platform and I'm
joined today by Peter Hitchens author
commentator who's just got a new book
out now on a revolution betrayed about
Britain's grammar schools in the 1960s
and 70s and I'm delighted to be joined
today bye Peter to discuss it and the
PC's written for the spectator all about
it Peter welcome pleasure to be with you
um let's start with the book which is
you know why this book um why now I
should have written it long ago I've
known for edges that it needed to be
written I perhaps I'd hope that somebody
who knew the subject better than I did
would write it but it never seemed to
appear when I wrote my first book which
is now
I think more than 20 years ago the
abolition of Britain the subject came up
and I made some general remarks about it
and as I wrote the chapter on the
subject I realized how little I knew
about what had happened but set it to
one side for later and now what is its
seven books along I finally thought well
since no one else is going to do it it
has to be done
and it's also I I write books partly to
educate myself I've been engaging in in
what is a
45-year remedial course from the
University of Fleet Street to make up
for the failure of most of that
education and one of the ways of
educating yourself is to write a book
and so that you don't know anything
about now by the end of writing a book
you've still don't really know much
about it you're just about ready to
begin writing the book by the time
you've finished it as anybody I think
has written a book will confess the same
thing you but you've got you've got a
deadline you've got to write what you've
got it's it is it's been a great
discovery for me I found out fascinating
things I never knew before
that's a really interesting point about
rethinking certain things and you were a
grammar school boy no I wasn't no I I'm
a public school dropout
my wife was a grammar school girl and
it's it's as I say in the dedication
it's her
undying Fury it was was effectively the
murder of her South London Girls Grammar
School uh which is which originally took
my interest and has kept me interested
ever since and suppose what what did you
learn most what that surprised you from
doing this book
what I found that I hadn't really
grasped that I'd always suspected it
was that the secondary modern schools
which are always slandered by the
opponents of grammar schools their their
top argument is well if you bring back
Grove schools that's all very well for
those who get into them but what about
those who don't uh those terrible
secondary moderns those those as it were
refugee camps for dances and failures
where people were told all the time that
they've failed and were treated like
dirt uh it's just not true
the secondary ones of course there were
bad secondary ones they were bad grammar
schools there are bad private schools
there are nothing ever is is universal
but millions of people probably 10
million people passed through secondary
modern schools and had them as their
their most basic form of education and
became as far as I can see in in this
kind of productive uh constructive uh
intelligent citizens of the country and
they in fact we they're beginning to to
move on into retirement and to disappear
from among us but I think we'll probably
miss them and I came across this
extraordinary piece of work by Michael
dick Stroud which I the process of which
I can't stop singing called the
secondary mode he had been to a
secondary modern and from there had
eventually reached the University of
Sussex when it was quite hard to get
into to study Physics and his whole uh
belief was that everything that he heard
about secondary months didn't fit with
his own experience so he's done an
immense amount of of really good hard
research to the National Archive stuff
and was produced a work which seems to
me is a
deal a death blow to the to the idea of
the secondary moderns but some kind of
universal disaster or those who were
were sent to them Were Somehow
classified as failures and made to think
of themselves as failures so and I think
that's probably the the thing about the
book which is for me the most striking
Discovery area of new knowledge which
I've now got and when I wrote about this
in the mail on Sunday uh I did get a
fascinating letter from a from a woman
who'd attended the second month this is
exactly my experience I got a very good
education and so did the people who were
there with me and I get sick of being
told that it was that it was terrible I
just wonder why do you think the
secretary moderns became so demonized
and became the argument with the
abolition of the grammar school system
which I think probably was seen as
having a lot of Merit but it was
obviously the case in the secondary
moderns which was used as justification
for creating this new comprehensive
system sure and then there was the
extraordinary marks and Cox report
um of I think 1983 which showed that the
secondary moderns along with the grammar
schools were actually doing better in
exams in the new comprehension
which was pelted with slime at the time
and the authors tremendously unfairly
treated and so they eventually were
rescued by by Keith Joseph who was then
education secretary who Vindicated them
in the House of Commons and said that
their research was in fact respectable
but they they came under such attack
because they did something which nobody
had done no research had been properly
done to compare the actual effectiveness
of comprehensives against the schools
they'd replaced and here was some and it
was bad news for comprehensives and the
whole huge ideological utopian force
behind the introduction of comprehensive
schools was outraged by this and it's
another fascinating story again I I I I
I owe it to to Dick Strauss research
that I I know about who looked into it
and obviously the there was a grammar
school element there was a sex memory
schoolman element the third bit of the
tripartite of the 1944 Education Act was
technical schools
um and I just wondered if you did any
work on that as well no because it was
quite clear that in most places there
didn't exist there was one in my
hometown
uh Manchester made a serious effort to
create them but in fact there was no the
the the the 1944 act didn't really
prescribe a tripartite system as people
say it made possible for a tripartite
system to exist but who was going to
spend the vast sums of money necessary
to set up technical schools and the
answer is very few people and they
weren't really a major element I think
they would have been a very good idea
and I think if if you were designing an
education system for an advanced
industrial country then it's something
you should have done but we didn't
really do it and it I decided not there
would have been a lot of extra work for
a very small very small area of
knowledge I decided to leave it alone
but what we do know is that really it
was a bipartite system it was secondly
moderns or grammars and that was pretty
much it the other thing about the
secondary ones is they were their first
attempt by the the English States
different in Scotland and Wales the
first attempt by the English state to
set up a national system of free state
secondary schools nothing of that kind
existed before up till then it was
elementary education unless you could
get into a very small number of Central
Schools so called or or get a
scholarship to to the grammar schools
which existed before the war Elementary
education ending pretty much at 14 for
most people and so it was a completely
new
area of Education no one had ever done
it before in this country
and at the beginning it was completely
hamstruck in fact hobbled by a a pretty
much a decree from the labor government
that the new secondary modern schools
should not take external examinations so
for the initial years until the early
50s although some Headmasters did object
to this and tried to get around it in
most secondary ones you couldn't take
examinations so how could they possibly
they had no real purpose they were some
free thinking free-spirited schools the
type which the left keep telling us they
want that's why they weren't much good
to begin with as soon as they were
allowed to take exams they began to do
quite well you mentioned the left hand
you talk about being public school
dropout who goes to York University in
the 1970s and having as your Vice
Chancellor um Lord James and um I just
wondered what sort of changed from this
old school sort of Fabian socialist view
of uh sort of a Proto belief in
meritocracy and to then you then have um
who is the education secretary who
abolished her well Anthony crosson ended
up with the it should have been it
should have been Michael stew uh but
there's extraordinary events of 1964
which I personally remember whether the
horrible Peter Griffiths
yes stood in a racist platform in
smelling defeated as a result Patrick
Gordon Walker who had been going to be
foreign secretary as a result Michael
Stewart who had been the education
secretary and who would have been in
charge of destroying the Ground Schools
was moved to the foreign office so all
the opprobrium which sort of hit him
ended up in the life of Ashley Crossing
who richly deserved it I have to say but
it it was an almost an accident that he
ended up doing it but how did it go from
being you know grammar schools being
quite a sort of progressive cause to
then being the bane of the left well it
was an argument within the left until it
still to some extent is uh the very few
people on the left are now prepared to
argue in favor of gross there's quite a
lot of fabians for instance were
particularly uh Eric James's favorite uh
will were keen on on keeping grammar
schools and Rh 20 it was one of the
great the great supporters of ground
schools and the the Durham the county
Durham labor party which is the first
local Authority ever to become fully
labor and which had built and and
expanded for our schools for for the
working class of that area and had
created before the second world war
system very like the one which would
come into being in 1950 44 elsewhere
they were all in favor of it but the the
labor party by then had begun to attract
an awful lot of ideological utopians uh
and and they they were they were much
Keener on the idea of the the common
schools they call it the idea that
Society could be transformed to be more
democratic and more equal if only
everybody went to the same school and
it's a very fine ideal you can see why
people embrace it uh but the the truth
is that when it was tried it failed for
various rather obvious and predictable
reasons in fact the man who invented the
term comprehensive School Michael Graham
Savage
who was himself a quite a distinguished
teacher and introduced the idea having
gone to the United States and seen their
high schools and thought they were more
democratic than our system
he admitted that there were drawbacks
that would be an increase in equality it
was a loss of quality and was quite
clear on this and towards the end of his
life he expressed some regrets about
what his idea had brought about so there
were all kinds of currents in there but
one of the other cards which nobody
mentions the the about the comprehensive
movement is particularly people such as
Brian Simon who was the great
intellectual force behind it whose books
uh the the the driving force behind the
comprehensive experiment was in fact an
active and diligent member of the
Communist Party of Great Britain and was
beyond doubt amongst this revolutionary
and
this sort of the comprehensive
Revolution appealed very much to people
of that kind and to the the increasingly
importance middle class utopian left in
the labor party which grew up in the
personal period you mentioned there
about how grammar schools have very
little traction on the left these days
in the labor party
um how did the Tory Party come to accept
this idea and obviously the infamous
everyone uses his Margaret Thatcher
clothes more grammar schools than any
other education secretary I think the
Tories were ever that interested
notorious politicians certainly until
recently have generally sent their
children to private schools anyway and
they were knew little about about
grammar schools which were the Great
Divide but you know Eden Eden's original
charter is as a grammar school The Great
Divide came in the 19th century when the
the Clarendon commission Public Schools
separated themselves from the other
grammar schools by by becoming boarding
schools and therefore by taking people
from from from all over the country rich
people from all over the country rather
than being schools for their locality
and the grammar schools continued to be
local schools for the local middle class
and that's that's where the Great Divide
began I think an awful lot of political
Tories uh had taken the public school
the boarding school path and were not
really particularly either knowledgeable
or interested
they did feel the need
to come up because they they could see
the sensible ones towards the end of the
second world war they were going to be
done over by the electorate uh for their
pre-war performance and indeed for the
for messing up the uh the years before
the war they wanted something which was
both cheap and effective to make
themselves look socially Progressive and
I think they embraced the idea of the 44
act providing free secondary education
for all for that reason but that was
whether Interest really ended they never
really defended grammar schools on
principle Tory local authorities from I
think the early 50s were building
comprehensives on new housing Estates
because it was cheaper and and simpler
and less controversial very few new
Ground Schools some but not many were
actually built between 1944 and the at
the end of drama schools in 65. many
many more needed to be built the
provision was incredibly uneven in some
parts of the country that were hardly
any and others like Wales there were
huge numbers and there was very fine
education system but and when the great
baby bulge came sweeping into secondary
schools in 1956 the the schools were
completely overtaken by it because they
no one had bothered to build the new
schools or recruit the new teachers to
cope with its influence and so what
happened was very large numbers of
people who ought to have been able to
get into grammar schools on the on the
level of intelligence and ability they
had could not get in that's when The
Crisis began until then the
the common school utopians had been a
sort of shouting minority on the left
but once the middle class began to
suspect that they were being treated but
their children were not getting into the
schools they thought they could rely on
then it became a big political issue
that's a fascinating the tourists ran
away at that point they weren't prepared
to control it the point about like we
said earlier in this discussion the
point of lack of funding for technical
schools and then the fact that they
failed to build it so often the case of
personal burden is a failure to plan I
didn't do it and with the people David
Eccles was a very smart guy as education
Minister she as he was there in in the
50s and he foresaw this and the the
gurney Dixon reported I think 1954 also
foresight and said something should be
done to expanded School provision but
you know what governments are like yeah
and the idea is Australian people can
see it's a good idea but someone's got
to squeeze the money out of the treasury
which I think by that time was in the
hands of Brad Butler who started the
whole thing that wasn't prepared to pay
for it I was always very telling isn't
it
you stop being so keen on the things
that used to motivate you um I wanted to
ask I mean in terms of the future then
it seems like your conclusion for the
book is it's unlikely grammar schools
are ever going to come back I can't see
it because apart from anything else
where would you find the teachers it's
an enormous
it would be an enormous project to
restore them it was done interestingly
there is a model for this when these
German Communist Regime collapsed it was
it was mostly a comprehensive country it
was
it was a complicated quirk in this which
allowed senior party members to get
their children into bed
for most people it was it was because
I'm sure it was it was comprehensive
schools all the way up and the parents
all over the the former Christianity
went to their new local governments and
said can we please have our Ground
Schools back and the answer was yes I've
been to one in in visma and the Baltic
and very inspiring it is too but Germans
probably uniquely of all the major
European nations have experienced Utopia
egalitarian societies and they know just
exactly how bad they are in this country
we haven't we don't really understand
uh just how bad it can get so I don't
think there's the there's the the
political force of the popular desire
and also I say how do you where are you
going to educate them in a country whose
universities are now comprehensive and
you will learn the schools what are you
going to get teachers uh and how are you
going to come up with us a method of
selection which will get political
support you don't have to have the 11
plus you don't have to select at 11 for
instance but it would be extremely
difficult and extremely expensive and I
just don't think that's the the
there's the support for it I hope I'm
wrong almost all the things I say all
the pessimistic things I say I hope that
I am wrong and I'd be delighted if if
people would prove me wrong but I don't
see it as very likely at the moment what
people do need to know is how this
disaster happened so they can spot
disasters of the same kind happening now
and prevent them
very interesting feature I look forward
to reading it all in full and uh thank
you very much for watching view from 22.
[Music]
[Music]